tout aussi inutile et elle est grande
offensive terrestre
en 1916 les armées sont enterrés depuis
deux ans les tranchées allemandes sont
soignés rationnelle à l'image de leurs
ingénieurs
elles sont profondes ils conduisent à
des abris enterrés pour les chevaux à
des cuisines à des magasins
les alliés doivent reconstituer leurs
stocks de munitions et attendre des
armes lourdes ils s'enterrent à leur
tour sans réaliser qu'ils devront encore
pendant deux ans vivre dans la bo les
canons les mitrailleuses sont aussi
enterré chaque ouvrage couvrant un
secteur la guerre est gelé généreux ils
peuvent rien et cependant ils préparent
sans cesse des offensives toutes vouées
à 200 grands échecs l'opinion publique
accueille très mal quand elle en est
informé
ces massacres aussi dutil ses pertes aux
innombrables
pendant toute l'année 1915
les jeunes recrues d'angleterre ont
appris à creuser sous l'oeil sourcilleux
des vieux sergent quelques années plus
tôt l'armée avait réformé les pelles et
les pêches au nom du modernisme
maintenant on dissèque devant les bleus
l'anatomie d'une tranchée et les
ouvrages de défense enterré on montre la
tranchée principal les postes de guet et
les réseaux de barbelés derrière la
tranchée principal une tranchée de
soutien un réseau de tranchées d'accès
et des tranchées de réserve ponctuée de
redoute avec des centres de
communication
en théorie le système est parfait et les
tireurs sont protégés derrière les
barres ap en pratique c'est un lacis de
vins et de prix
où
les allemands choisi de creuser dans les
sols plus élevée dans quelques secteurs
le drainage de leur tranchée est assurée
vers le bas ou les avions gros et les
leurs jamais il n'avait plus autant sur
la terre de france
les paysans disait que c'était à cause
des tirs d'artillerie qui croivent et
les nuages vient de l'eau partout mais
bien peu d'eau utile elle est polluée
par le chlore des obus à gaz l'eau qui
est livrée aux premières lignes certes à
la consommation pas question de
l'utiliser pour se laver et
correspondant de guerre évoque l'odeur
tenace une humanité qui ne se lasse pas
le front vie dans la crasse et dans la
bon
devant la tranchée est déployée la ligne
continue des fils de fer barbelés ainsi
que les ouvrages de protection
au delà c'est le no man's land où la
mort n'a pas de vacances des chevaux et
rend 6 fauteuils de no man's land s'est
constamment des hommes en patrouille qui
doivent rentrer dans leur ligne avant
l'aube et qui risque de se faire tuer en
enjambant le parapet les généraux ne
supporte pas l'inactivité
les envois constamment des hommes en
patrouille par exemple pour faire des
prisonniers et les interroger
aux tranchées les heures coule lentement
dans la routine des heures et des heures
d'assoupissement de la guerre tous les
jours des bombardements presque à heure
fixe
de temps à autre le bruit devient
infernal les nuits s'embrase avec des
fusée éclairantes et des os payant des
toiles
le fantassin fini par aimer sa tranchée
une maison qui est sakho qui sont ni il
réalise qu'il est devenu comme un animal
quand il doit dormir les bottes aux
pieds les vêtements détrempés collante
au corps dans la boue infesté de rats et
de vermine la sinistre boudon les poilus
ne peuvent se dépêtrer pour les blessés
ni plasma by sulfamides la malédiction
des tranchées ces deux frappes mal les
éclats d'obus
non
en
dans les tranchées il faut toujours
combattre que ce soit les 1000 froid les
ras la glace labo pour porter la soupe
aux pois lieu des tranchées il faut les
héros ces gens-là risque de se faire
tuer cent fois
une chanson du front dé la guerre n'a
pas de répit ce n'est pas vrai les
troupes sont périodiquement retirer de
première ligne pour aller au repos dans
un village français de l'ariège et
médias on y soigne l'hiver les pieds
gelés au repos on sait pouilles
l'immunité ne dure pas longtemps même
après le bain le plus chaud possible
malgré la lessiveuse où l'on fait
bouillir les vêtements 24 heures plus
tard dans la tranchée les totaux sont de
retour avec les rats et personne n'a
jamais réussi même avec des chiens et
des chats à se débarrasser des rats
l'expression favorite de fonds
fait rien tout est égal mais à quoi bon
faire la fine bouche
chacun dort à la même enseigne pas de
privilèges
pas de chichi tous égaux c'est la
camaraderie des tranchées
la mort et ses ornements elle est si
proche qu'elle devient un personal les
morts peuvent rester sans sépulture
pendant plusieurs semaines dans le no
man's land avec le drapeau blanc ont
fini par les évêques mais c'est plus dur
d'en tirer les copains que de les voir
mourir en attaque
retour en lingala tranché tenir encore
un peu plus longtemps
les généraux ne renonce pas à briser la
ligne ennemie
ces gens là ne renonce jamais ils
retrouvent leur vieille ruse
ils en inventent d'autres il y allait
saper les sapeurs qui creuse en dessous
du no man's land
quelle joie de faire exploser une mine
sous les positions ennemies et d'ouvrir
une large brèche
pour l'observation il y aller tour
élevée et camoufler ou les observateurs
renseigne les artilleurs
à moins de deux kilomètres des lignes
ancrés au sol les saucisses ou ballon
d'observation dangereux très dangereux
l'hydrogène s'enflamme facilement quand
les chasseurs ennemis surgissent
il faut sauter bas à chute ou brûlés
vifs
on préfère encore sauter
les avions militaires ne font plus
seulement de la reconnaissance ils
mitraillaient bombardent des banques
primitif qui ne font pas de mal les
hommes redoutent les petites flèches
dassier qui tombe des avions il assure
que ses flèches de la taille d'un crayon
personnes et casqués les cloue au sol
une légende des tranches et bien sûr ses
flèches ont certes était produite est
lâché mais au début de la guerre et en
petites quantités
des armes et rend jamais vues sont
expérimentés les reverra t'on jamais
aucune ne change les équilibres du franc
les ingénieurs militaires s'épuise à
construire d'inutiles gadget
même les lance-flammes cette invention
diabolique allemand ne change rien parce
qu'ils ne sont utiles que quelques
secondes
les gaz asphyxiant avec le vent peuvent
se retourner dans les lignes d'eau ils
ont été larcher au première attaque les
français et canadiens non tu que leurs
mouchoirs trempé d'eau pour se protéger
les anglais les français mobilisent tous
leurs chimiste et parviennent à
fabriquer aussi des gaz
la guerre est désormais masqué 1
millions de blessés ou de morts par gaz
pour échapper au fléau
il faut naturellement porter le masque
mais les masques arrive trop lentement
sur le front
on essaye aussi les armures les armures
individuel à l'épreuve des balles
mais les armures ne servent à rien on
les jette où les broie
entre autres gadgets les français
inventa bouclier mobile poussé par un
fantassin rampant vers les lignes
ennemies
encore une invention tout à fait inutile
entre deux offensives il faut bien
passer le temps et faire oublier les
horreurs de la guerre
une de ses inventions va faire son
chemin des anglais ingénieux travaille
sur un tracteur armée blindés chenillés
et caterpillar
on l'appelle d'abord porteur d'eau pour
tromper l'ennemi plus tank wiston
churchill s'y intéresse pas c'est qu'un
colonel de l'armée du no d'airness min à
tous ceux qui gardent le secret de cette
fabrication sont loin d'y croire
comment sais tu en perds seraient ils ne
feront allemands qui sont trop gauche
trop peu maniable pour réussir vraiment
une percée
octobre 1915 premier essai pour les
tanks
ils sont gauche des lourds il avance à
la vitesse d'un homme au pas mais ils
peuvent franchir les fossés les trous
d'obus
il avance partout les voitures
s'arrêtent et généraux anglais du front
sont sceptiques
ils ont chassé les allemands de leur
tranchée distille bien avant l'arrivée
des chars à quoi bon des chars on a
besoin d'hommes dispose hommes de
renfort et il arrive de toul empire même
d'australie et de nouvelle zélande
voici les en zac avec leurs chapeaux et
leurs airs de bravache les canadiens les
indiens les sud africains des écossais
en kilt appelé par l'ennemi
les filles de l'enfer les grandes
parades d'infanterie prêt pour le grand
coup dernière course
celle qui doit définitivement percée des
lignes ennemies
en 1916 l'offensive anglaise est prévu
dans un secteur calme la vallée de la
sones sort de glace sfig qui commande
l'opération est convaincu qu'il va
couper en 2 l'armée allemande rien moins
il devra le faire tout seul car les
français sont saignés à blanc par le
massacre de vertain joffre qui supplie
les anglais d'attaqué ne peut leur
offrir qu'une aide morale un plan sans
intelligence
il prévoit d'assaut frontale d'une
trentaine de kilomètres de large sur les
deux rives de la rivière
six corps d'armée britannique est un
conte au nord et cinq divisions
françaises au sud
c'est trop attendre le signal du départ
la ligue allemande est incroyablement
forte les collines crayeuse qui
surplombe les lignes alliés sont de
vrais qu'attaquant bas des abris
charpente est renforcée de béton éclairé
à l'électricité
l'office riz des postes de secours des
magasins de réparation des arsenaux les
allemands se sentent bien dans leur
forteresse
ils n'ont pas envie d'être dérangés ils
pensent que les alliés seraient food
essayé d'enlever d'aussi fortes
pollutions l'armée du général entre
rawlinson s'avance position de combat
un demi million de touba hills se
tiennent près derrière les échelles d'
escalade il se bouche les oreilles des
canons lourds écrasé allemand depuis
cinq jours et cinq nuits
il
un soldat anglais attend le signal de la
soupe dans 20 minutes se dit il je
serais mort à quinze minutes je serai
mort tap les hommes s'élancent cours
tombe fauchés par la mitrailleuse
le premier jour est un désastre
par conquête de terrain appréciable
quelques avions de forêt à la fin du
jour plus de 60 mille soldats anglais
sont couchés dans les champs reg ne veut
pas renoncer ni admettre son échec il
n'admettra jamais pendant cinq mois va
se poursuivre la bataille la plus
stupide de l'histoire de l'angleterre
qui cependant est riche en bataille
stupide
juillet 1916 rawlinson croit apercevoir
une brèche dans le dispositif est nommé
il ordonne à quatre escadrons de sa
cavalerie indienne de charger les
rafales de mitrailleuses naturellement
couche les cavaliers dans un champ de
plaies
les chevaux morts on en comptera 600
milles
rien que dans les lignes alliés pendant
cette guerre on en achète d'urgence en
amérique on capture même les chevaux
sauvages les nos stands qui sont livrés
sans lit coup dès le premier jour de la
bataille de la somme l'infanterie
allemande contre attaque sous la
protection d'un tir d'artillerie
savamment minutes et les troupes
avancent et tombe sous le feu anglais
nouveau massacre
le tank alors entre en scène pour la
première fois en nombre dans la bataille
de cambrai 42 temps flambant neuf
elle compte sur eux pour percer la ligne
allemande
les équipages dominent à peine les
lourdes machines ils n'ont pas dormi
depuis 48 heures ils connaissent mal les
commandes de ce matériel révolutionnaire
où
à la vue des chars les allemands panique
quatre mastodontes traverse les lignes
de partants par neuf sont éventrés par
les aubes et d'autres tombent en panne
ou sont embourbés ceux qui ont traversé
les îles sont isolés attaque et détruit
c'est un échec jusqu'à mi-novembre le
massacre se poursuit dans le désordre
sans aucun bénéfice
le général elle comprend fa la vanité de
ses espoirs et la folie d'un tel
sacrifice
les britanniques comptent leurs pertes
400 à 1000 soldats les allemands n'ont
perdu que 2 135 mille combattants
la proportion est de 2 contre 1
il faut arrêter les frais il est clair
que sur le front de l'ouest
la décision ne peut pas surgir
londres est sinistre des visages des
passants sont fermés
le pays peut seulement nourrir sa
population de la nuit du vendredi
jusqu'au lundi matin pour les autres
jours de la semaine il faut apporter des
vivres
les lignes de ravitaillement sont
attaqué sans relâche par les sous marins
pour utiliser les stocks défaillante
vives pour être certain que les enfants
au moins pourront se nourrir le
gouvernement sert des repas préparés
dans les cuisines nationale il impose
rationnement pour toutes les denrées
seul le sucre est maintenant en vente
libre jusqu'en 1918 pour ne pas
désespérer les pauvres faire la queue
devient une routine les pommes de terre
sont si rares que les riches en offre
plutôt que des fleurs aux maîtresses de
maison
on manque de lait le lait est interdit
aux adultes mais il n'y en a pas encore
assez pour les enfants pas d'essence
le gaz de charbon est mesuré une
génération entière de citoyens
britanniques est balayée par les pertes
de la guerre en 1917 seuls les vieux les
femmes et les enfants tiennent le front
de l'intérieur
m
à
oh
on
les collégiens préparent leur départ à
l'accueil des classes entières de
conscrits sont balayées les enfants
mettant dans leur incorporation sont
soumis à toutes les corvées
ils travaillent dans les fermes à la
ville ils font des collectes
il n'y a pas de jaune assez jeune pour
ne pas servir le roi et le pays
encore
la dernières illusions tombent pas de
sécurité sur le front intérieur les et
plat les aéroplanes tiennent le ciel au
début les gens sortent dans les rues
pour les voir bientôt il se cache à leur
approche en 1917 3000 civils sont tués
ou blessés par les bombes tomber du ciel
l'autre georges le nouveau premier
ministre garde pour lui son
découragement
il paraît en public dynamique et résolu
s'il exige des sacrifices du front de
l'intérieur il veut diminuer les pertes
en france il prétend lever la conduite
de la guerre à ses généraux il n'a pas
confiance en eux il est très attentif
aux décisions du chef du corps
expéditionnaire britannique qui lui
paraît incompétence heures douglas fake
les in one ménagé c'est une favorite
georges 5 le jazz le trouve maladroit
insensible aux pertes même si elles sont
énormes
il lui préfère le français nivelles
auquel elle est subordonnée nivelles a
présenté un plan pour la victoire rapide
et sûre il a remplacé geof comme
généralissime nivelles propose une
double offensive au nord pour les
britanniques au sud pour les français
les anglais doivent attaquer sur un race
le 9 avril 1917
m
oui
la rupture du franc c'est la vieille
balançoires des généraux
à l'extrémité de la ligne anglaise les
hauteurs de vimy une avancée du front
déjà des milliers de victimes et
canadiennes sont chargés de sens dans
pareille enterré c'est un enfer de très
lourdes pertes mais nivelles nivelles
qui a promis la victoire en 48 heures
il ne se soucie ni de la surprise n'est
de la météo sans importance dit il pour
une armée décidé à vaincre
polytechnicien nivelles a fait ses
calculs le coût ne peut pas manquer
c'est du moins ce qu'il dit
après une violente préparation
d'artillerie dont on attend monts et
merveilles 40 division française
s'élance et tombe dans le vide
l'ennemi a restreint ses ning cacher ses
défenses et français se font de
massacrer au chemin des dames
deux cent mille morts en quelques jours
soldats français après ce drame vont se
mutiner
m
ils veulent désormais faire la grève de
la guerre trop de blessés trop de
gueules cassées
trop de gaz et sur toute la ligne les
régiments ce meeting est sa révolution
dans les tranchées jamais plus généraux
français n'oseront demandé une offensive
baïonnette au canon
les poilus ne sont pas des bolcheviks
ils en ont seulement marre de la guerre
cinquante cinq divisions sont affectée
par les mutineries
aucun leader révolutionnaire au front le
mouvement est spontané les politiques
pense que ce mouvement peut être
terminée
non
c'est pétain qui prend les choses en
main 554 condamné à mort mais seulement
45 exécuté pétain revoit le régime des
permissions et la rotation des unités en
première ligne les officiers sont
désormais conscients qu'ils ne peuvent
en donner que des actions limitées et
bien préparé ils doivent reprendre en
main la troupe lui rende sa confiance
dans le commandement
les officiers anglais doivent aussi
faire face à des révoltes les allemands
le même changé unités du franc ils se
défient des recrues qui viennent de
l'intérieur
partout concurrents la révolution
adieu
à
adieu tout
c'est la pluie
c'est pour toujours
attaquer
c'est pas un
c'est le pari
obama c'est sympa
pas nous savons tous
en mai nous ce soir
et ça
en angleterre la propagande guerrière
fait beaucoup de bruit mais les gens en
ont assez
les prix ont doublé les sous-marins sont
plus actifs que jamais les ouvriers sont
pris par le recrutement pour remplir les
vides des unités les manifestations
organisées pour soutenir l'effort de
guerre ont pour slogan gagné la guerre
mais qui les écoutent encore dans le
désarroi des esprits ailleurs ancrée
fini c'est la guerre les mouvements de
protestation explose un peu partout les
mineurs vote la grève
sur tous les bassins l'angleterre les
ouvriers des usines de munitions les
suivent
détesté par la clique milite à l'air
suspect aux yeux des politiques est peu
appréciée par le roi le d'orge passe
pour un dictateur mais il réussit à
rassembler la nation pour le dernier
effort à briser les grèves
révolutionnaire il engagea conservateur
churchill connu pour son énergie il
était en disgrâce depuis la malheureuse
affaire des dardanelles et bien il
reprend aujourd'hui notre george hotz
talent au ministère des munitions
le lion est en place il n'arrêtera pas
de rugir
le roi lui même est attaqué sa cour est
pleine d'étrangers dit en allemand qu
d'esprit combatif le roy réplique qu'il
soit d'année s'il est étranger il change
le nom de la maison royale qui était
d'origine allemande
il l'appelle désormais maison de windsor
ainsi pense-t-il personne ne pourra plus
critiques qui la famille royale il
annonce un changement décisif dans la
guerre navale
le pays attend une politique nouvelle
sur mer pour lutter contre les
sous-marins une mission vient d'arriver
des états unis conduite par l'amiral
william chips sim s'est indigné par
l'importance des pertes des années sur
mer il réussit à convaincre l'amirauté
que la réponse à la menace sous marine
c'est l'organisation des convois la
grande bretagne n'a plus que six
semaines de vivre elle décide
d'appliquer le plan sims en peu de temps
les pertes sont réduites de moitié
oh
washington est maintenant convaincu
qu'on peut envoyer en france une grande
armée mais celle-ci n'existe pas encore
en attendant les américains aig veux
courir la chance de sa vie on
l'autorisent à lancer une offensive
seulement britannique sur ton front
c'est la troisième offensive des
flandres un risque politique énorme
après la période des mutineries et gâte
accra sur la ligne de crête de messi na
pa chaîne d'al il poussera en avant pour
libérer les ports de belgique est
terminée la guerre avant que les
allemands de perçu de fond français
affaiblis la plus grande opération de
creusement de tunnels de la guerre est
entreprise messine en face des lignes
allemandes les mineurs du pays de galles
le pays de l'eu d'orge viennent
renforcer les sapeurs du génie pour
réussir la plus énorme opération de sape
de toute la guerre en secret ils perdent
19 tune
il met en place 500 tonnes d'explosifs
au dessous des positions allemandes
le coup d'envoi est donné à l'aube du 7
juin 1917 de londres le job j'entends
l'explosion à plus de 200 kilomètres de
là au 10 downing street à sa résidence
de premier ministre les vitres tremble
e
vingt mille allemands sont tués ou
estropiées on capture 7000 prisonniers
totalement choquées elles demandent la
permission d'attaquer sur la crête de
pas chez total
notre georges d'abord s'y refuse et puis
s'y résignent il a un mauvais
pressentiment grande offensive commence
en juillet 1917 sur un champ de bataille
transformer en fonderie hier par des
torrents de pluie des troubles au but
les allemands sont enterrés
il dispose de canons lourds
les assaillants séduisent une nouvelle
stratégie salon sur le terrain détrempé
des flandres
un général britannique visite en plus
tard le champ de bataille
s'écrie bon dieu nous avons réellement
envoyer des hommes combattent là dedans
pendant quatre mois d'automne la
bataille continue sans merci
elle prétend qu'il a réussi à percer le
front c'est faux il a pris le pont de
pas chaîne d'al mais le front n'est pas
percé et les pertes sont innombrables et
guette un grand chirurgien ni churchill
en grinçant des temps et il ajoute sa
haute capacité professionnelle
l'empêchent de voir l'agonie de son
patient
trois cent mille britanniques sont tués
blessés ou disparus dans la boue et gars
seulement gagner quelques arpente
marécages
toutes les femmes d'angleterre se
dévouent pour les blessés et le rudolf
distribuer les décorations survivants il
n'a pas pu éviter la dernière offensive
de leurs règles mais il a du moins
éviter à son pays martyrisé le plus
grand de tous les maux la révolution on
peut redouter qu'en 1917 l'allemagne de
keyser ne s'y précipitent l'europe
entière va-t-elle tourner au rouge
pour conjurer le danger révolutionnaire
le pouvoir civil en allemagne haptique
de plus en plus en face des militaires
massifs et rassurant hindenburg héros
national et pour l'allemagne l'image du
père une volonté d'acier mais protecteur
responsable il a pour adjoint le
quartier-maître général erich von
ludendorff qui est après hindenburg
l'homme le plus puissant d'allemagne
les listes des héros morts ou blessés
s'allonge
notre seule fierté a coutume de dire le
2 nov
et que nous combattons face à des forces
très supérieure et que nos lignes sont
en dehors de notre territoire sacré
c'est un faible réconfort pour une
nation qui craquent les fonds de gav
pour se chauffer l'hiver et qui est au
bord de la famine
les allemands sortent tous les jours
pour voir affichés sur les portes des
mairies les listes des morts des
disparus des prisonniers tout est
rationnée en allemagne le recrutement
enlève les mineurs et des fermiers la
production chute le blocus alliés réduit
les importations étrangle le commerce
maritime dans l'industrie on manque à la
fois de main d'oeuvre et de matières
premières
on fait la queue dans les magasins pour
obtenir des denrées alimentaires qui
bien souvent n'existent plus ou qui sont
des ersatz les allemands appellent ce
temps l'hiver au chaud
des millions d'hommes et de femmes
mangent des choux une ménagère allemande
se souvient de s'être gelé ventre creux
dans un foyer sans électricité
le pétrole est lui le manque et même la
grèce pour les bougies
la détresse est supporté par patriotisme
mais les artistes ne se gêne pas pour
illustrer aigrement la réalité
kate kollwitz par exemple dont le plus
jeune fils est mort au front
le dessinateur georges grèce soldats
réformer pour dépression nerveuse crocs
l'arrière du front sans aucune groupe
les ans
ses dessins sont tout à fait dans
l'esprit des observations amer le propre
fils du désert
le conte prince j'ai vu dit-il un
changement immense et menaçant dans les
rues de berlin les gens des classes
moyennes ont perdu leur air satisfait
ils traînent dans les rues le teint pâle
les yeux creux dans des vêtements élimés
à leurs côtés piaf des profiteurs qui
les boudent ce pull pour prendre toute
la place
mais propagande officielle et glorifient
les as de l'aviation
les capitaines des sous marins mais
généraux du front auto dicks en présente
les soldats comme des victimes dans la
guerre telle qu'il l'a peint il n'y a
pas de place pour la gloire
tél
par eddie du quartier général tout ce
qu'il ya de meilleur sur le marché doit
être réquisitionnés pour l'armée le
dender demande au front intérieur de
supporter la misère de faire des
sacrifices
les besoins de l'armée prix
les citoyens mange du pain noir mais ils
doivent envoyer des colis aux armées
l'armée a priorité absolue ainsi et
éviter la révolution dans les lignes
ouais
dans les zones occupées de france de
belgique et de pologne
des unités de l'armée sont affectés au
travail dans les fermes pour être sûr
que les récoltes seront saisis à la
source les allemands de l'intérieur ne
recevront rien de tout cela
alors
le travail forcé fourni de la main
d'oeuvre des régions occupées ainsi que
les camps de prisonniers de guerre mais
ces travailleurs supplémentaires sont
autant de bouches à nourrir une charge
de plus pour l'économie titubante et
cependant la main d'oeuvre étrangère est
essentiel dans les fermes dans les
usines les pour entretenir les voies de
communication avec le front un
prisonnier évadé raconte que grâce aux
colis de la croix rouge qu'il recevait
régulièrement ils mangeaient mieux que
ses gardiens
on récolte à domicile les objets en
métal pour nourrir la production de
guerre
on utilise la ferraille les batteries de
cuisine mais les gens donnent aussi
leurs anneaux d'or et leurs bijoux les
biens comme les vies la guerre a arraché
ton la dernière de laine sur le dos d'un
peuple déjà habitué aux plus terribles
prévention les industries allemandes ces
puissantes grésy sous l'effet d'une
tension excessive les matériels s'épuise
la puissance se perd
les ingénieurs sont au front traçant les
plans de guerre l'allemagne jadis et
dynamics exténué dans la grisaille d'un
crépuscule de guerre
le reichstag expriment le mécontentement
général au nom du case et à une
tentative de paix est amorcée du côté
des alliés par le chancelier de bethmann
holweg séides pitié devant une misère
indicible
n'est-il pas possible de trouver une
base d'entente dit il mais les alliés de
sont nullement prêt à négocier avec une
allemagne qui ne croit qu'à la force
le chancelier est il prêt à discuter sur
l'alsace et la lorraine
demandent les français le parti de la
paix une fois mises en échec le gender
fait hindenburg s'empare du contrôle du
gouvernement
la politique intérieure explique le
quartier met général doit être dirigée
par ceux qui sont responsables des plans
militaires
les généraux persuade le désert de leur
accorder les pouvoirs ils veulent le 1er
février 1917
ils obtiennent de lui la liberté de
reprendre la guerre sous-marine intégral
qui pousse le président wilson à entrer
dans le conflit
les allemands croyait pouvoir étrangler
tranquillement la grande bretagne sans
que les états unis bouge
c'était la conviction du secrétaire
d'état allemand aux affaires étrangères
arthur lieberman
l'amérique ne fera rien dit il parce que
wilson est pour la paix et rien d'autre
en février les sous marins avait coulé
800 mille tonnes de navires
seul un navire sur quatre quittant
l'angleterre revenait au port
l'ambassadeur américain à berlin a été
rappelé
l'entrée en guerre des etats-unis sauver
la grande bretagne mais le choix de la
guerre totale par l'allemagne
sauvé aux six pays de la révolution en
accordant les pleins pouvoirs à l'état
major
elle pousser l'aventuré jusqu'au bout